hello and welcome to this video playing
men see here on leech has three plus two
Blitz people tend to play the stuff
now with Knight f6 c5 is a bit odd very
early they play is six normally probably
taking is certainly correct so let's do
it
and now just wonder okay there's the
main threat I just wonder here put if
you would maybe put the annoy the f9 on
to deform a little bit
you know interesting very ambitious what
he's trying to do here trying to get
trying to play this with losing lots of
time but get the bishop out it would
seem one thing is that the knight on e4
doesn't have many squares so in some
cases that can be an issue so quick
Queen a force most normally am attending
Bishop b5 should be three I could have
played Bishop b3 immediately actually
and this is an interesting this is also
okay I guess there is six also as an
idea in this position it seemed
something like six now this piece should
be five and that probably won't work at
all for black
okay I just overlooked this one not sure
that it actually works but I didn't look
at it
always hurts to lose against bad opening
plane
and if you him if you overlook moves
like that you deserved him I don't even
have a playable continuationists the
awful thing I mean like something that
is remotely playable
yeah King takes a king moves I cannot
play should be too is also lost
so maybe when Queen a1 is playable maybe
even yeah it is playable Quincy 1 is
made its a mate threat made us a strong
threat and I cannot move this as Queen
takes e5 will also be killing this I can
move was I can claim where's the Queen
going now
Quincy 3 Bishop t2 who this isn't so
clear this isn't so clear actually he
could have just taken on d4 that was
possible and now wait what is he doing
now
mmm queen bee one I guess well this was
one okay okay now if I take c6 this
couldn't be one check so ok f3 that's
Bishop d7 I couldn't be one I have not
see one it's not a big deal
maybe Bishop d7 mm-hm
okay let's come to intermediate check
also
and stretcher box this in a little [ __ ]
you can also pay Roxie aide
they I don't have I don't have enough
here remotely not even remotely enough
he's six and so on he can develop can
just develop
I still continue a little bit you never
know it's not really
nothing really going on
the time is ticking down a little bit so
now I go create and now you will manage
and what wasn't sure before you didn't
play it well at all giving me chances no
it's definitely lost yeah it was it was
bad it was really bad again I always
hate to lose against bad opening plates
e5 is pretty bad but you know you have
to refuel it probably just Bishop e3 or
something I mean black black you cannot
play like that it just doesn't work
we should be three is the way to refute
it okay these six you know you cannot
play the six for example like what you
would like to do because there are all
those discoveries in like yeah the
discoveries even this is possible why
doesn't the engine give that okay
because something I'm the most
convincing yet the relatively best yes
Knight takes like something like that is
just terrible the knight has no squares
you cannot play six and so on black is
passed away that opening just doesn't
work like that
but I'm blundering here Queenie for is
just grows I actually wonder if I had
chances because I don't think this was
good yeah I'm somewhat back in the game
and here I wouldn't be I wouldn't want
it wouldn't be surprised if I have
something okay we should be five it's
already okay Bishop c1 is okay Knight
takes c6 what I did is not okay not
surprised I mean there must be some
compensation but that that is defending
you know there's just nothing I can do
I tried around and he gave me some shots
and spits chants this wrong but there
were certainly ways to win quicker it
looked a bit like it there's just no way
to do it Queen g8 continues oh here I'm
lost
hey I just have to kill them in the
opening if they play so badly you have
to kill them there should be three
assists just although probably Queen B 3
is also strong this is also very strong
it's like yeah you six is the only move
really everything else is bad for luck
c3 is right yeah because I need to
prevent this Queen before stuff and
queen a4 and so on this is this is too
much sugar for ambition we should be
free it's just very obvious good and
they're obviously good the Queen has no
squares also I mean you can go here that
the additional problem is that there is
a 6 plus Queen b3 so all this like this
is an absolute nightmare of a positional
you know with with this this this way of
Swiss structure yeah this is a game that
should end on live 20 but this is just a
big blunder then I never can recover
form it's just terrible me okay guys
thanks for watching